leider ist total ab dem moment
fokussiert man lebt im hier und jetzt
man es in faszinierenden landschaften
anja blatter zieht beim training in
zürich alle blicke auf sich die reifen
sollen einen schweren schlitten im
schnee simulieren
es ist das optimale training für den
extremsport im flachland aufgewachsen in
den bergen rekordhalterin erst mit 25
kommt die bielefelderin zum bergsteigen
innerhalb von drei jahren bezwingt sie
die seven summits die jeweils höchsten
gipfel der kontinente
sie ist die jüngste deutsche die den
mount everest bestiegen hat musste
miterleben wie jemand gestorben ist man
überlegt sich aber eben auch wofür lebe
ich und welche risiken bin ich bereit in
meinem leben einzugehen und für mich ist
das das risiko wert dass ich dass ich
sterben kann in diesem sommer bezwingt
sie dem zweithöchsten gipfel der welt
dem k2 ohne sauerstoffgerät als erste
deutsche frau der nächste rekord
ich mag gerne immer wieder was neues
entdecken erleben und immer ein stück
weiter gehen als ich es bisher gemacht
habe um zu schauen was was ich noch
erleben kann
nun bereitet sich anja blacha auf ihr
nächstes abenteuer vor
es ist vielleicht das gewagteste allein
mit ihren schlitten 60 tage im ewigen
eis
er hatte von der küste der antarktis bei
1400 kilometer bis zum südpol gehen
der startpunkt ist auf bördner island
und geht dann über das eis auf die
kontinentalplatte durch gebirgszüge und
dann auch das polar plateau dass man
hinterher am südpol selber angekommen
ist am geografischen ihre ausrüstung ist
minimalistisch und praktisch da es
unterwegs keine versorgungspunkte gibt
muss anja blacha alles selbst mitnehmen
akribisch hat die 29-jährige ihre
verpflegung zusammengestellt insgesamt
66 kilo und die werde ich alle in
tagesration verpackt auf meinen
schlitten tun ganz viel
gefriergetrocknet ist endlos viele nüsse
haben super viele kalorien auf 100 km
entsprechend gut und auch einen hohen
fettgehalt viele süßigkeiten butter
pulver einfach das ganze noch
weiterzumachen dann habe ich einiges an
protein pulver dabei ich werde jeden tag
sport machen und die muskeln haben
praktisch keine zeit für die
regeneration also es wichtig dass ich
den möglichst eine gute versorgung
bietet
noch nie ist eine frau soweit allein
durch die antarktis gelaufen
ihr einziger kontakt zur außenwelt zwei
satellitentelefone geprobt hat sie ihren
trip in grünland szenario zum anderen
habe ich angst davor dass ein kritischer
ausrüstungsgegenstand um jetzt zerbricht
und nutzbar wird und das dritte dass ich
mich einfach überschätzt habe ein
letztes training anja blacha fühlt sich
gut vorbereitet auf die wohl größte
herausforderung ihres lebens